[Musique]
vous
vous avez année
un nez très grands
traits
c'est tout mais au nom c'est un peu
court jeune homme on pouvait dire dieu
bien des choses en somme en variant le
ton
par exemple
agressif moi monsieur si jamais un tel
nom il ferait sur le changement [ __ ]
amical mais il doit tremper dans votre
tasse pour voir fait vous fabriquez à
annappes
descriptif c'est un roc de trafic c'est
un cap que 10 c'est un cap c'est une
opération
curieux de quoi sert cette oblongue
capsule d'écritoire monsieur ou de
boîtes à 6o gracieux et mais je vous
assure point les oiseaux que
paternellement vous préoccupe at de
temps dans ce perchoir leurs petites
pattes
truculent ça monsieur lorsque vous payez
la vapeur du tabac vous sortez le dîner
sans qu'un voisin ne crie au feu de
cheminée
prévenant gardez vous votre tête
entraîné par ce point de tomber en avant
sur le sol tant fait lui faire un petit
parra salle de peur que sa couleur au
soleil ne se fane pays dans l'animal
seul monsieur karysta fans à
l'hippocampe éléphanteaux camelo ce
doute avoir sur le front autant de chair
sur ton de
cavaliers quoi la mise crowe est à la
mode pour pondre son chapeau c'est
vraiment très commode
emphatique auquel on ne peut les
magistrats le temps rue mais tout entier
excepté le mistral
dramatique c'est la mer rouge quand il
saigne admiratif pourra parfumeur quel
en scène lyrique est ce une conquête
vous instruis ton naïf ce monument quand
le visitent ton respectueux souffrait de
ce qu'on vous salue c'est là ce qui
s'appelle avoir pignon sur rue
campagnard r dès cette année non cech
n'avait je m inquiète melon militaire
pointé contre carli pratique voulez vous
le mettre en loterie assurément monsieur
ce sera le gros lot enfin parodiant pire
à mon un sanglot le voilà dont ce n'est
qu'il est très leçons m a détruit
l'harmonie
il en rougit le traître
voilà donc à peu près mon cher vous
m'auriez dit si vous aviez un peu de
lait trait d'esprit
mais d'esprit le plus lamentable des
êtres vous n'auriez jamais un atom et de
lettres vous n'avez que les trois qui
forment le mot so
us évoluent d'ailleurs l'invention qu'il
faut pour pouvoir l'a devancé noble
galerie me servir toutes ces folles
plaisanterie que voulant lui sied pas
articuler le quart de la moitié du
commencement du
quart
je me laissais à moi-même avec assez de
verve mais je ne permets pas d'un autre
les servent
[Musique]